yo what up Chris Pratt here for BuzzFeed
talk in question or confession do you
and Peter quill have anything in common
we have a lot of common and I think that
my particular spirit is breathed into
this character and I think I've been
part of the collaborative process of
bringing this character to screen and in
a way helping to create who he is
confess whether or not you believe in
aliens
my guess is our understanding of the
cosmos is completely wrong whatever we
think is right is is not I'm confident
in that but no I don't believe the
variance if you had to trade lives with
Peter quill emmet brickowski or Owen
Grady who would you pick and why
probably Owen Grady because I like earth
you know and I like being a human and
he's good at riding motorcycles and I'm
not
so I'd say Owen Grady confessed to one
thing you do at home that bugs ohne the
most my guess is and she would never
tell me this but I think I'm a man's
planer cuz everyone so I'll ask rusty Oh
was I just mansplaining just now she
goes no what's the best part of
returning to film a sequel people say
like how are you possibly gonna like
outdo the first movie and guess what we
did we managed to find a way to surprise
you and out do what we did in the first
movie to not only meet but to exceed
these raised expectations and that is a
testament to the genius of my friend and
director James Gunn confess was junk
food you'd miss the most if you were
abducted from Planet Earth by the
seven-layer burrito from Taco Bell this
is a gut bomb I'm glad I don't eat it
makes me feel like I eat that thing and
I'm and I it feels so good and I
immediately regret it I just like don't
even know what they put in it like let
paint or something because it's like my
guts hurt so bad but it's still want
more marry kill
Pizza alcohol Chris Evans married Chris
Evans kill alcohol pizza I think Chris
and I would be really happy together
what was your favorite scene to film in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 the long
James gun ask Guardians Brandon
rapid-fire comedic scenes that are like
six to seven eight pages long those are
fun confess whether or not you ordered a
meal for your kid just so you could have
a few bites I'd finish my food
fast cuz I'm like grew up and went to
prison family and there was never enough
seconds for everyone so you always had
to finish first so you could get the
second and then the next thing I do is I
just start looking at honest food and I
just reach over and start taking food
off her plate and she doesn't say
anything but I have a feeling they might
really bother her because my son is just
like her but but not conditioned to be
so sweet
and so I start taking his dad that's my
hey that's my food you just ate my food
dad like oh I'm sorry I didn't even
notice I was doing it sorry son well
that's it no more confessions or
questions
[Music]